You know what,
like kind of like Jamie said,
it's dangerous in a lot of ways.
It's dangerous to control people's thoughts and behavior because who are you to
say and when does it end?
You know,
it just keeps going and going and going and going.
It gets,
it gets very slippery when you have one group that thinks it's right and they're
trying to control another group that thinks they're right.
Man,
that is a,
it's,
it seems so simple when you're just talking about dead naming transgender people
or not degrading people based on their looks or their ethnicity or their this or
their that.
But what you're doing is you're trying to dictate how humans communicate with
each other and people don't like it when you tell him what to do.
The problem with telling people what to do is they want to do the exact
opposite.
This is one of the first things you realize when you have kids like,
oh,
they don't want to listen to me.
Like,
I got to figure out a way to sneak information into them,
you know,
or you gotta you gotta figure out a way to not be too bossy.
People don't want someone telling them what to do.
This is what I missed when I was edited,
headed into that conversation.
I missed how other people looked at that guy and what he stands for.
I don't think it's correct.
I think it's way more complicated.
I think it's an insane business to run it.
No,
I don't think he really knew why Alex Jones was banned or what anybody else has
been.
I don't think he really knew.
I think he's dealing with a giant corporation and he's a young guy and he wears
sandals.
Like come by here on,
wait,
what kind of Sandoz?
There's a weird ones.
Nice guy.
Like leaning on Bro.
Let's just choose.
He runs a couple of different companies.
He's not,
he's not sitting at Twitter offices.
That's another thing that Alex Jones brought up today that uh,
he sponsors the podcast through the,
the cash app,
which is also,
he also runs so 100% true.
But I would have,
and I think we talked about it on the podcast,
we even talked about the cash app being a sponsor and about how it's helped
Justin wren is fight for the forgotten charity.
So Alex Jones or ruinously said that I didn't mention it so we did mention it.
It's worth mentioning and Alex Jones is a,
he having to like respond to people that want to know if I've seen what Alex
Jones is said about me lately is one of the weird things that I've dealt with
because first of all I've always had good dealings with Alex in person,
person to person,
but he's obviously in a world of shit right now.
There's a lot going on with him with the sandy hook stuff and he wasn't entirely
honest with me about what he had said about Sandy Hook.
Maybe he didn't remember.
Maybe he was trying to phrase it in a way other than the way I interpreted it
when I saw the videos,
but there's a media matters video that shows all the time where he said that
Sandy Hook was fake.
This is a very complicated,
to me,
this is one of the reasons why I struggled with bringing him back on the
podcast.
That's very complicated.
It's that is even though,
um,
I've known the guy since 1998 and if I'm around him,
I'd say that's my friend Alex Jones.
He's a friend.
He's off.
He obviously did something fucked up and the parents that had to deal with what
he did,
there's parents that had to deal with people calling them a crisis actor.
They had to deal with people harassing them at the courthouse and harassing them
if they met them in public because they were saying that they were lying about
their kids being killed.
So not only the kids being killed,
but they have to deal with someone harassing them and saying,
you're a liar and you're enactor.
It's insanity.
And I wouldn't,
I would think about it differently.
I've definitely think about differently if I wasn't friends with Alex,
but it would also think about it differently if he hadn't made shit up about me.
He said that I was told to stop talking about conspiracies or they threaten my
family.
That's a hundred percent horseshit and he has my phone number.
He could have called me.
I called him after I heard about it.
He told me that someone told him that I talked,
I talked to the person who told him that I'm like,
this is fucking bananas.
Like you out of your mind,
call me.
This is so stupid.
You think I'm not talking about whatever.
Fill in the blank.
Whatever.
Ridiculous conspiracy,
the Rothschilds,
the fucking Rockefeller's,
whatever it is.
I'm not talking about that because the government threatened my family.
That is fucking wrong.
It's ridiculous.
And now you've put it out there.
So Alex Jones went on afterwards and he apologized and corrected it.
Then recently,
because I haven't had them on the podcast,
he decided to start saying that I worked for the CIA and then um,
uh,
George Soros talking points,
which I don't even know what he's fucking talking points our talking points
about him and specific not talking to anybody.
No one's giving me talking points,
not George Soros.
That's not what Eddie Bravo has been saying.
He got it.
He got good.
He got good information through even say that.
So stop.
Joey Diaz did fuck with Eddie for awhile though.
But,
but the point being,
the point being Alex is you're out there.
I still like you as a person.
If I saw you,
I'd still give you a hug,
but you're making shit up and this is,
this is not helping.
Anybody wants to defend you.
It's not helping me as a person.
Talk about the good qualities in you and you know the,
these things that you're saying are made up.
You're making up the fact that I'm in the CIA.
You're making up for the fact that the Hollywood insiders have given me
information and tell me what to say.
That's not true.
You know,
it's not true.
You know me,
I don't have time to be a CIA insider.
I can't take on another job in between doing standup and podcasts and UFC
commentator running a family.
I can't do it.
I wouldn't do it.
I'm not interested.
I'd rather stop doing everything then work for any government organization.
No one's ever approached me.
No one's ever approached anybody I've ever heard of.
I don't even know if that really happens.
I don't know if that's real thing.
The thing is they will say is that the CIA would talk to the people in Hollywood
and tell them what to say in terms of propaganda and maybe,
I don't know.
I don't have any personal knowledge of it.
I'm sure someone has decided that if they're going to make a movie about like
zero dark 30 that they have to get some sort of approval and I'm sure that a lot
of movies that are very inspirational that I have to do with the military,
it would be great for recruitment.
So I'm sure there's some involvement.
I'm sure there's also some patriots that work in show business that want to put
out these movies about the government and about the military and a very positive
way.
That's probably the case in some instances too,
but not everything's a fucking conspiracy and this is why it's stupid in white
stupid is some things are fucking conspiracy and Alex Jones has talked about
some things that were real conspiracies.
That nine 11 documentary,
the road to tyranny details,
the World Trade Organization protests where they sent in these agent
provocateurs,
the,
which are essentially soldiers.
They send in soldiers and military people dressed up in all black and cover
their face and they smashed windows and tip over things and they take a peaceful
protest and they turn it violent so then the police can move in and shut down
the protest.
And then not only did they do that,
but they made a no protest zone and the United States of America,
uh,
no protest zone.
Was it the United States of America wasn't Vancouver was it was Seattle I think.
No,
I think at Seattle World Trade Organization protests with the boots and they all
have the same shoes.
Yeah,
that shit.
But Alex detailed this in detail and it was real when he makes things up.
Like there was one recently,
the David Pakman show had on about a Alex talking about people eating babies
pituitary glands and scattered vandalism of downtown Seattle.
Yeah,
Seattle.
See,
so the enforcement,
no protest zone.
That was in 2009 in 1999 rather
was it [inaudible] 99 yeah,
December 1st,
1999 the October 27 2009 was the article.
Um,
yeah,
Alex did that.
That was real.
That was legit and it was very informative because I didn't know that that is
how the government operated sometimes.
Did you contact him the second time and go talk to him?
I sent him a text message,
so this is why I won't talk to you.
You say crazy stupid shit like this,
but I don't hate the guy.
He's,
you know,
he'll scream and yell and call me a demon.
He's not a good place.
You're not in a good place when you're defending against that and what all these
other conspiracies like it's all fun and games until you're talking about
people's kids getting murdered and then all of a sudden people are like,
fuck you.
And that's basically what happened with him.
If he was just ranting about government conspiracies or you know,
who shot this guy or who's stealing money from here.
Some of what he talks about is beneficial,
but Alex is not,
I don't think in a good place.
I don't think he's in a good place mentally and I don't,
I don't think he's in a good place in terms of his situation with the law.
I don't hate you Alex Jones.
If you listen to this,
if I saw you,
I'd still give you a hug.
I'll still even do your fucking show when I come to Austin.
I don't care.
You can,
we can come and hang out,
but just stop making shit up.
It's silly.
And you know,
I'm sorry if there's bad stuff between us a more sorry of what you said about
those kids.
I'm sorry about everything.
Um,
it's,
it's unfortunate.
It's all terrible now.
Something like that.
What's the road to redemption for someone like that?
Cause some,
this is the thing about people is,
and I think this is also what's going on with Alex.
People need a road to redemption.
Like if,
if someone fucks up horribly and does something terrible,
should that be the end of them?
This idea that we don't need them anymore,
no matter who it is.
I mean what,
what does a person have to do to grow and learn and for,
for people just accept them again and let them on to all platforms again.
What,
what,
what does a person have to do?
It's a real good question.
I think it's per person now.
Like somebody like Alex to seems like he's getting worse and worse.
Like this seems like what he did teach us.
You is just doing it to me cause it's mad at me cause I haven't had him on that.
He,
I'm sure he asked you or if he was in town,
I'm sorry.
No,
no.
Do you not listening?
I said I didn't want to have him on one.
I was trying to figure out whether I would have in mind but when I watched the
media matters video it was very clear to me he wasn't being on.
I asked him if he had said that it was fake and he said he questioned whether or
not it was real.
But then eventually he acknowledged that it was real,
which he has done.
But there was many times where he said it was fake.
Not One,
many times.
It's absolutely fake.
It was a hundred percent fake.
There's video of it.
I didn't see the video before we did our nine 11 podcast.
I've seen it now and I still thought about having a model.
It's still thought about talking to them about it and talking to him about all
this shit and what it's like.
I think it's,
he plays a character.
Honestly.
I don't think so.
I mean their rep tiled guys and people and the things that he says,
none of it.
Half of it's just like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I think he,
he definitely goes,
goes crazy with
things,
but I don't think he's doing well.
Um,
but he was talking about eating babies pituitary glands.
Where at Cvu find that David Pakman video.
David Pakman who's a progressive,
a commentator online.
He,
he was going,
look,
something's wrong with him.
Like he's playing this video,
like what he's talking about them breaking into more
what is happening in the Alex Jones.
Yeah.
See if you can find the part on the video where Alex is talking.
It's early on.
It sounds like schizophrenia.
It sounds like any episode of the live PD or a cops,
you know,
and people are talking like,
I saw aliens upstairs in my house,
you know,
like the guy,
I wouldn't Benjamin
look at him,
he played this place real quick.
Okay.
It's all in plain view of these people.
They're just put it in our face and they want a system where we can't do
anything to stop them.
That's like a Domar.
And the name of his production company is Sha kid love,
which is isn't Apple's slogan.
Basically,
they may shows about having sex with kids all the time and says it's okay to
have sex with,
you know,
kids that have section 35 year olds from the 12 just incredibly outrageous,
evil,
pathetic stuff of these solace demons
like Bill Maher.
But,
uh,
Josh was saying he had a theory,
the only one what?
Walnut sausage,
and I know you would say it's the pituitary gland because they confirmed the
Jimmy Chevelle and others would a torsional kids to death.
But I think because we get regular wants to kill,
if everything was to grab a kid,
run over more the cars,
they could say,
oh,
there's a police report.
They get run over.
But they would hurry to the morgue and they work with different,
different governor controlled morgues and eat the pituitary gland as quickly as
possible,
uh,
and,
and get high off of it.
So yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's,
yeah,
that's first of all,
Bill Maher has done a fucking pedophile.
This,
this is crazy.
This is like a weird rambling,
and this is not Alex that I knew from 1998.
It's just not,
it's not the same guy.
This guy not doing well.
So my apology,
um,
as a human being to Alex Jones,
if,
uh,
you were hurt that I didn't have you back on the show.
If you are hurt that I've occasionally poke fun at you,
I have to.
You're hilarious unfortunately.
But,
uh,
I don't hate you.
Don't wish you wish you badly.
And,
uh,
back in the day I enjoyed it.
A lot of your stuff,
people lose their way,
you know?
So
I think that,
um,
it's a real bad feeling being stuck on the outside too.
When they all band together and kick you out and everybody kicks you out.
Everybody,
Twitter,
Facebook and everybody and Youtube and Twitter was the last one.
But,
uh,
that was Jack Dorsey didn't even know why l Sean's got kicked off Twitter and
people are like,
well,
let them back in then.
Like,
yeah,
but somebody knows like somebody,
like,
I don't think Jack Dorsey is really the guy who's looking at each individual
person that gets banned.
I just have a feeling that that stuff is compartmentalized.
Right.
I felt he thinks it's about the people hunting for 7 million monthly active
users on there.
Right.
But how many people are,
um,
responsible for banning people and real high profile people?
I'm sure there's a whole,
like maybe 12 people.
They have to have a meeting.
Then they,
you know,
maybe they talked to Jack.
Maybe they don't,
maybe they,
it's an opposition who,
yeah.
Right.
And he may be,
he doesn't,
we don't know.
I'll ask that for sure.
But maybe he didn't know when people got banned until he liked maybe got a
company memo.
Maybe he wasn't involved in the,
of course,
maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe he's the one that calls him up and said,
get rid of this motherfucker.
That's possible too.